we are very excited for our next guest I
mean very very excited actor and
comedian Andrea Savage she's the Creator
writer and star of the acclaimed comedy
series I'm sorry and she's also known
for playing president Laura Montez
opposite Emmy winner Julia Louis Dreyfus
in the hit series Veep now and here's
the really really exciting part Savage
is taking a dramatic turn in the new
Paramount plus series Tulsa King
alongside movie Legends Sylvester
Stallone he plays a New York mobster
forced to rebuild his life in Tulsa
Oklahoma and Savage plays an ATF agent
Who develops you could say a complicated
relationship with him it's a show that
has already been renewed for a second
season it's only been out for about a
month here's a clip
what happens in your work
someone loses their
inputs their
associate
someone who counts on them at risk
probably wouldn't turn out so well
do you remember the last time we were
together he said
you couldn't help me if I got jammed up
what can I say
I guess I should get my job
Andrew Savage joins us now good morning
I've been quoting the show and trading
lines all morning not all of them say
for this kind of TV probably not
probably not but you're making very good
TV on Paramount plus and we appreciate
that
thank you I'm happy you guys like it
you're very excited uh Andrea Beal ATF
agent
listen where Andrea starts Stacy
that's the mark of a good actor how
would you describe your Alter Ego hcf
agent Stacy Beale oh thank God I'm not
Stacy Beale
um Stacey Beale is um listen
she's lonely she similar to Sylvester
Stallone's character has been pushed
into Tulsa Oklahoma
and she is going through a divorce she
has no kids she has no family real
friends and she just has a connection
only to Sylvester Stallone's character
who is
much older than her and also a mobster
and she's an ATF agent yeah and that's
her only sort of little spark of Joy it
gets kind of messy and the scene we saw
I will have I do point out she didn't
really have to give him that news in
person but I think she kind of likes him
even though she shouldn't even though
she's on the side of the law listen when
you're lonely your intentions might be
different than your follow through yeah
well there's something magnetic about
Sylvester's character
um there's also something magnetic but
magnetic about him
um yes but sheer character yeah but
sharing the the stage if you will with a
guy like that is it difficult because I
mean it's it's Sly right I I was nervous
and I don't get nervous but I definitely
we had not met before and we were
shooting the scene actually where I
propositioned him oh wow that's the
first one and that was literally like
Hello nice to meet you here we go
um but we did like a little read through
of the lines and he kind of like did a
little like if I'm more of a gentleman I
wouldn't ask you that or whatever he did
a kind of thing that's just live voice
right there
it's not good
um but then I was like oh are you a guy
who just like talks with his hands a lot
or something and I kind of made fun of
him a little bit and I could have gone
either way and he laughed and then we
were kind of like Off to the Races I
mean you guys are both not only actors
but writers and creators so was that a
connection point I think it was I think
because both of us do wear a lot of hats
we definitely thought about the scenes
in similar ways we both would come in
with some ideas about maybe changing a
line or why this or yeah I definitely
feel like I never thought I would say
that I had a would expect to say I had a
lot in common with Sylvester Stallone
own yeah but I was like oh we actually
kind of are similar in a lot of ways so
one of the things I love about this
character is it's a tough strong woman
um but you have done these incredibly
hilarious comedic roles we were talking
in the Green Room about that I loved her
and Step Brothers yeah of course talk
about Step Brothers all the time classic
you were saying and you were incredible
in Veep but you said that you know you
never see you've only seen Step Brothers
I've only sought once and then so when
dudes come up in like that will come up
to me all the time and they quote lines
at me the most inappropriate stuff no
idea what they're saying they'll be like
I traveled 3 000 miles to give you my
seed
excuse me
exactly and then they're like weren't
you in Step Brothers I was like oh right
right right okay yeah that one movie
that has a cult following yes so what's
it like now in in this sort of
non-comedic role I mean there are some
there's some dark comedy some dark
comedy well I wanted to do I've pretty
much only done comedy um after I'm sorry
we got you know middle of shooting
season three shut down the pandemic then
we got caught in a merger and all this
stuff happened and after that I was like
I'm not ready to go back onto a comedy I
want to do something that kind of scares
me I was like I need something at this
point in my life
that I haven't done before where I'm
nervous and also terrified at the same
time speaking of something that's scary
um I'm gonna parent to a teenager is
scary I got a 13 year old as we know
so do you finders are not safe for TV
I'm sure mine are either do you find
some humor in that though you know you
know what found it to be honest funnier
when she was younger because that's when
they say things that you're just like oh
that's tough to figure out
now you know what I mean or you know
you'll be like sitting in your jeans
with maybe a little
flesh coming over and she's like why is
that happening on your body okay how
little they say that oh yeah she speaks
her mind they had no filter now she's
just now I'm just the most embarrassing
human that's ever existed yeah I didn't
know you're the coolest mom ever that's
what I tell her as well and you're in a
very very hit show for Paramount Blossom
we appreciate it well that's that's
teenager Vibes that's what they do we
care we do care I appreciate it you're
all my new children thank you very much
the new episode of Tulsa King I don't
know I've seen I'm sorry I'm not sure
about that
Monday exclusively on Paramount plus
which like CBS is a division of
Paramount global